well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages with me now is the
assistant comment editor of the
telegraph olivia utley and the political
editor of wales on life ruth mozalski to
take us through those newspapers welcome
to both of you and so to the front pages
then let us start with the guardian the
british plan to send channel migrants to
rwanda is top story for the guardian
which reports that the scheme has been
widely branded as inhumane
inhumane is also the word used as you
can see on the front page of the mirror
the daily mail quotes boris johnson as
saying he won't let the plan be wrecked
by what he calls objections from the
left
the telegraph leads with the story of a
british man fighting in ukraine who has
been captured and paraded by russian
forces sky is not showing the russian
picture of him in captivity in line with
the geneva convention on prisoners of
war
the sun leads with news that harry and
megan have flown to the uk to make a
secret visit to the queen and prince
charles the paper says well the star
again turns its ire on the prime
minister for breaking lock down rules
but refusing to resign
reminded that by scanning the qr code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
plenty more of those papers still to
come in but let us go to our guests now
olivia and ruth who join us um and not
surprisingly the the rwanda plan olivia
is highly controversial um does it have
benefits as far as you're concerned
well it's very interesting i was
speaking to some polling experts today
who were saying that immigration illegal
immigration in particular is the one
issue which is still very much split
along traditional left-right lines and
you can see that in tonight's papers
you've got the guardian sort of slamming
from slamming it from every possible
angle there's no mention of any possible
benefits and the mail which we'll talk
about later uh explaining why the policy
might work and and might be a good thing
uh the the telegraph's view on this is
that uh
again and again it's very very clear
that people in britain do want illegal
immigration to be curbed people in
britain are very worried about those
illegal crossing routes where people are
risking their lives in the channel and
wants something to be done about it and
pretty patel with this is at least
trying to do something serious about it
she does at least seem to have a plan uh
whether that plan will work is it is
another issue i mean in australia
offshore processing has worked um and it
has massively brought down the numbers
of people coming to australia illegally
uh rwanda seems to be a relatively
sensible choice i think there's quite a
lot of racial stereotyping in rwanda
which is quite surprising especially
from the left that we that we've seen
today um and actually you know rwanda's
much more than just sort of byword
genocide it's it's a thriving uh nation
uh so so i think there's
some of that today which has been a
little bit odd but i think there are
definitely merits to plan um and i do
think it's just very interesting the way
this debate has become so polarized and
sort of traditional left right lines and
so all we see in the guardian is is the
criticism of the plan without real
explanation uh of what is of what's
going on here
yeah well the rwanda um you might say
and it has been argued today is hardly
democratic the last election in august
2017 was won by the incumbent by
98.8 percent of the vote which uh is is
kind of unheard of in democratic
elections is it not um ruth what about
you and we've heard a lot of the
criticism that is inhumane practically
what do you do how do you march people
onto airplanes and then effectively
abandon them there um so what's your
take on this and whether there were
alternatives to this plan
yeah i think olivia's right people
people may want something doing about it
it does come out top i think that the
poll in today was that conservative
support this is something around 59
whereas labour support is about 15
so clearly it's on party lines um but i
just think
i i don't think it's fair to say it's
racial stereotyping i think it's the
fact that
this is a plan that's come from nowhere
lots of people today were saying why
rwanda why this country
pratel said today you can't compare it
this to the australian scheme it's a
completely different thing and so i take
olivia's point there is lots to be
talked about i think the reason lots of
people who have come out so strongly on
this
is quite rightly there are so many
questions
um how much is it going to cost simon
hart the world secretary was talking
about this this morning on the broadcast
rounds it was 120 million he was talking
about i'm not sure anyone thinks it's
gonna cost that um is it also right that
it's costing five million pounds a day
or is it sustainable it's costing five
million pounds a day to put people up in
in hotels here at the minute no it's not
so yes something has to be done is this
the right plan
we don't know that yet and part of the
reason we don't know that yet is because
it's a plan that's come
seemingly you know prince of health can
say it's been negotiated for months i
think simon hart said the same this
morning
but for lots of us it's come from
why are we picking this plan why is it
one-way ticket why is it single men
because there's an awful lot of
questions the answer's best well it was
i mean it was this idea was mooted
several months ago wasn't it you know
albania was thrown into the mix and
certainly the prime minister said today
that this had been negotiated
uh with the rwandans for some nine
months so it's as if to put down the
idea that it's not part of operation
save big dog olivia um you know
where is this come from for the
government has it come from watching
what has happened in australia or is it
simply exasperation that they can't get
anything out of the french and the
european union to tackle this properly
well i think it's a mixture i mean nick
timothy theresa may's former advisor is
one of our columnists and i speak to him
a lot and
he's been interested in this plan for a
long time it was mooted back when
theresa may was in government so i think
the idea that it's come as a sort of
lightning bolt out of the blue uh isn't
quite right although of course there are
lots of details which are yet to be
discussed um yes i think there's
frustration that that no no agreement
can be reached with the french um and
obviously there are just so many hurdles
there and i think to be honest neither
side has has been negotiating in
particularly good faith uh but but
i think there will be a lot of people
both in government both in parliament
and outside of it who are quite relieved
that that at least something is being
done and and we're hearing sort of quite
a lot of labor complaints uh yvette
cooper particularly was was was talking
about how much it's going to cost per
migrant which is
again not really talking about the issue
in good faith because the entire point
is that it's supposed to deter people
and in that way at least i think it it
can be compared to to australia's policy
which has deterred people so so to say
it costs you know x million pounds per
person is a bit of a nonsense because
because the whole point is that fewer
people will come so so yes it's
expensive but how much more expensive
will it be if if this uh policy you know
if our immigration just illegal
immigration just spills further and
further out of control um so i think
there will be a lot of a lot of relief
that tonight that something will be done
is going to be done about it and and yes
there are still huge questions about
exactly how it's going to work but i
think generally priti patel's ratings uh
were very low both among conservative
voters and among the country at large
and i think this is probably going to
give her a bit of a boost she now does
does seem to be one of few cabinet
ministers um who are who is prepared to
sort of put their neck on the line and
and do something quite brave and bold
and different i think the idea that it's
going to sort of save boris johnson's
skin is is nonsense too i mean it's not
a sort of safe easy policy to just throw
out and make people happy it's going to
be very difficult a lot of people won't
like it so i think it is at least a an
attempt to deal with the problem at hand
uh whether it'll work as we say another
another question entirely yes pretty
patel obviously going to uh kigali
herself uh to have that meeting in that
news conference with the rwandan foreign
minister there um we go back to uh well
let's look at the daily mail as well
shall we talk about this the pm i won't
let the left wreck rwanda plan there are
many people
who simply think that this will never
come off that it will be mired in the
courts that legally there are all sorts
of issues um about this and the other
point he made today was that pilots who
bring people over um you know will be
held in jail and the deterrent is there
now i guess you could see a scenario
where the pilot hands the keys to the
refugees and says right drive yourself
and you end up seeing more um you know
very difficult circumstances in the
channel so what do you what do you make
of the deterrent effect of this and will
that work
i think what we haven't talked about so
far is the human aspect of it isn't it
that you know none of us want to see
those images even today as boris johnson
was making his speech a baby was being
carried ashore i'm not sure anyone can
imagine that the choice that those
people are making when they're on
um the coastline and trying to decide do
you know do i get in the back of this
lorry do i get on this boat
um
the the the comments from boris johnson
that he will take on the army of
left-wing lawyers and lord dubs was on
sky early tonight i think talking about
how and he just doesn't think this will
get through this isn't just as simple as
the uk government want it to happen
they've signed a deal with the random
government and there's pictures of that
therefore it will happen there's a
really long way for this to go and light
mps will get a safe the lords will get a
say uh lawyers will get a say this this
is not um an easy sell for boris johnson
um but you know labor have made the
point today and that's been a point made
by secure stammer and wales as leader of
mark drake but but they do just think
the reason this has come out today um is
that it's a cynical and stunt to try and
distract and partygate and in lots of
ways it's worked hasn't it it's on the
front page of every paper we're talking
about it um
everyone has been talking about it
saying asking lots of questions so
it's a really you know
in that as cynically you'd say it's
worked
many people said they did not know about
it um the parish council in linton on
ooze which would have an raf base
repurposed as an asylum reception center
under these government plans so they
were not told about it uh the times
though suggesting that the pm is in a
bit of a hurry about this and wants it
to start in weeks olivia can you see it
getting off the ground that quickly
i think as we've said you know there are
huge obstacles to it but but i think we
over play as a sort of westminster
bubble the whole dead cat strategy thing
and the idea that everyone's always just
trying to distract from a bigger story
the prime minister and the government
has wanted to get ahead of this channel
crossings problem for a long time now
we're now seeing an influx of ukrainian
refugees and a huge amount of pressure
on both the cost of living generally and
on on our services so it's not really
surprising that the government now wants
to to get this issue in hand and and as
as i've said i mean and as we've as
we've discussed um you know
this plan has been in the offing in some
form for a while now there's talk of
albania as an offshore processing ground
um theresa may's chief advisers were
discussing it sort of years ago so so i
think at least part of it is you know
we're now out of the kind of immediate
covert drama and there is now just a
little bit more government space to sort
of talk about this and process it um i
think it's true that the government's
trying to push it through as quickly as
possible they want that momentum behind
them and they know that there are going
to be these obstacles in the law in the
lords and in the european court of human
rights so they want to show and be as
bold and pushy as they can about it
which means that they probably haven't
sort of jumped through all of the all of
the correct hoops and and it's you know
this town in yorkshire clearly should
have heard more about it before their
their uh village which is going to be
used as a processing center um but it it
shows a sort of government initiative
and it does feel as though the
government's keen to kind of pull its
socks up and get something done and i
think there has been a there's been a
feeling in the air in the while now and
i talk to conservative mps quite a lot
who sort of feel like
sometimes it's not quite clear what
boris johnson wants to do with power
other than sort of hold on to it and he
gets through the kind of partygate thing
but what's the point apart from sort of
to live to fight another day and i think
this sort of shows that the government
at least kind of has a plan a policy
that it wants to push through and it
wants kind of lead um so i think there
will be quite a lot of people as i say
hopefully outside of government too but
definitely inside government and
parliament who are quite relieved just
to see sort of something being done and
some kind of measure being pushed
through and seeing a little bit of
momentum by behind the government here
uh perhaps it will help describe from
partygate um
if perhaps it won't we all still seem to
be talking about it yes we will see
won't we um hof and i also won a
prospective by-election and local
elections obviously as well um which are
interesting for the government uh
obviously in power
including this story on the front page
of the telegraph business section elon
musk says his bid for twitter aims to
defend democracy discuss that in just a
moment
[Music]
back to both of you
ruth let's head to the
remembering which paper it is the
guardian apologies uh which has on its
front page the news that broke about
nine o'clock this evening that the
flagship of the black sea fleet this
russian vessel has in fact sunk
yeah so this ship um was being towed we
believe to crimea and and while it's
while that's been happening it is it's
sunk and that's been confirmed by
russian state media and as with any
story coming from ukraine at the minute
both sides are saying different things
and ukraine is saying that it was their
missiles that caused the damage uh the
russians say that it was an ammunition
fire and i think as deborah pointed out
earlier on the program either way for
the russians uh
it's not great um particularly in
regards that if it is a success story of
the ukrainians and it's obviously a huge
pr boost for them this was the ship that
um
when it tried to uh get near ukraine
there was there were some choice words
and it was sent on its way so it's a
huge pr victory for them and but the
statement from the ministry has said
that this cruiser ship lost its
stability when it was toured to the port
because of the damage the ships hull
and that it received during fire from a
destination of ammunition and so it's a
huge piacou for the ukrainian side and
uh and the opposite for the russians
and just uh passing through let's take a
look at the front page of the daily
telegraph which covers the story of a
british man aidan aslin originally from
newark trent in nottinghamshire who was
seen handcuffed with a gash on his
forehead and a swollen eye on russian
state television
having apparently been captured in
mariupol now many people have been
following his story from earlier in the
week when he got in touch with his
family and said he was surrounded and
would have to surrender we're not
showing those pictures because of
conventions on prisoners of war just
very quickly on that olivia
i mean it's absolutely grim and the same
from his mother is just horrible um and
it's sort of the first time that the war
has been brought home to to britain
specifically uh it's awful to see and
his mother's plea that he'll be treated
with humanity who knows whether it's
going to lead but i know we'll all be
following it very closely in the in the
days ahead and uh also staying with your
paper just quickly to business section
elon musk um this multi-billion dollar
bid for twitter
yeah so elon musk wants to save twitter
for for free speech he says he's not
interested in making money from it but
he wants to make it a true platform for
democracy and and for free speech um
it's not at all clear whether whether
twitter is going to accept this bid um
there's already
twitter shares have plummeted they know
it's going to be a really steep uphill
ride for musk shares and tesla have gone
down too so not clear whether he's going
to get it but he's got a plan and he's
he's going to fight for it so we'll see
over overnight yeah and just very
quickly i want to show everyone the sun
uh it claimed a royal world exclusive
it's now in a number of the other
newspapers uh prince and not prince
prince harry brother and megan uh jetted
into the uk for a secret face-to-face
meeting with both the queen and prince
charles a whistle stop tour their first
joint uk trip since they quit royal duty
in march 2020. we will know to have more
on that to come for now though ruth and
olivia lovely to see both thank you both
very much indeed